[Music]
i was inspired by the matrix the matrix
changed my life
to get to be here again it's really
pretty
it's incredible an iconic part of cinema
of entertainment
this is not a retelling this is a new
town
being a part of this film
with the performances the writing the
ambition the scale the scope the thought
provocation
it's been now taken to another level
[Music]
in terms of the matrix world we're back
inside
we come to learn that thomas had a
nervous breakdown in the past
he's having these episodes feeling like
he's in a different world than he's
actually in
[Music]
i have an analyst in the film he has me
taking blue pills to help me
and at the same time thomas anderson
meets this character tiffany who we
would recognize as trinity
have we met
tiffany is a mother and a wife and
has a love for motorcycles and through
her conversations with thomas anderson
she
senses that something isn't quite right
with her life i began to wonder if i
imagined you
[Music]
this is his apartment
there is this group of people who still
believe that neo was out there and still
believe there's unanswered questions to
get to the bottom of
bugs is a true believer she thinks that
neo is still alive so she has this sort
of rag tag crew with her and they're
just off in search of him time to fly
i'm really really excited about
introducing this new matrix to the world
i think people will like the directional
change that lana's taking she's not just
tried to make the original film again
everything that's come before this
present it's been synthesized and
practiced in a way that you have to be a
master filmmaker to make a film like
this
period
[Music]
we can't see it
but we're all trapped inside these
strange repeating loops
billions of people just living out their
lives
oblivious
but this is the moment for you to show
us what is real
[Music]
i remember this
[Music]
so deja vu
and yet it's obviously all wrong
maybe this isn't the story we think it
is
they taught you good
made you believe their world was all you
deserved
but some part of you knew that was a lie
some part of you remembered what was
real
it's so easy to forget how much noise
the matrix pumps into your head
something else makes the same kind of
noise
war
the most important choice in neil's life
it's not his demand
she believed in me
it's my turn to believe in her
[Music]
part of me feels like i have been
waiting my whole life for you
if you want to see trinity again
i saw this in a dream
my dream ended here
[Music]
i still come for
[Music]
you